there's only one place where I see
people moving around as much metal as
you guys do here in the Forge but we
can't have you guys forged there so we
brought it to you
and that place is
the gym
right here in this setup we've got a lot
of different types of Steel some of that
steel is hardenable some of it is not
you'll have to combine one piece of
hardenable Steel and one piece of mild
steel to forge a signature blade in your
signature style that falls within the
following parameters the length of the
blade must be between 11 and 14 inches
and the overall link must not exceed 22
inches your three hour Forge time starts
now
Off to the Races cool common collection
Jake
me and the other contestants we all kind
of pitched in and helped one another get
our steel take the whole thing over how
do you want to chop it up I think I can
tell if a steel is Carnival or not but
what it was used for is it being put
under a lot of stress is it meant to
flex but not Bend
I'm choosing the barbell and the Twisted
barbell
the straight bar has to hold more weight
so I think the straight bar bill will be
much harder steel than the Twisted
barbell making a sand mile would be the
easiest way to go about making the blade
I want to make because it's the easiest
way to stack it up and get in the forage
quickly I determine that the curved
barbell is softer steel so I weld it on
to the outer sides of the longer piece
of Carnival Steel in the middle
and I'm a little nervous but I think I
got this
Jake has grabbed one of the bars to the
dumbbell
I've seen people put 900 pounds on that
thing and it flexed but never breaks so
I know that it's going to be a good high
carbon steel I'm gonna do a stand my
Damascus with the mild steel from the
casing of the the bench itself
it's super important to get your steel
clean before you do a forged weld
because any impurities can damage your
Weld and get you not to stick
cut out I'm just going to go ahead and
stack them on there and Floors weld them
as fast as I can and get it rocking
I picked the steel off the leg curl gets
a good Pete and hardenable steel try to
get the blade shaped out first then
we'll add the secondary piece into it
my forged welding skills was a little
better I try staying my or a taco or
something like that
I'm gonna try a complete safe
I have to lose some meat off of this
grind it to safe and heat treat it
Rex is really getting that blade ground
down to a really fine look I'm gonna use
a piece of mild steel from the frame in
the handle
bins that the test is uh plate chop I'm
just putting the mild Steel in the
handle that away uh when it takes that
big jolt it doesn't shake loose or or
come apart I use the semi technique so
that the outer shell of the blade is a
little bit softer and can absorb some of
the shock to smash it into that weight
stop baby my welds seem like they have
stuck [__] and I realized that
there was some d-lams along the spine of
the blade hoping I can get these d-lams
out of here
I don't want to grind all the mild steel
off but I need to fix these d-lams along
the spine of the blade
Brash that has quenched it oh yeah
it's worked
it's worked all over the place so I'm
gonna do a signal winch
uh and freaking out I never have warps I
never have this problem at home
when you do multiple quenches you can
get cracking your wells to split
you can get all sorts of kinds of
programs
our Braxton what
I intervise being held straight
do you suppose that he's going for an
edge quench that looks exactly
punch it again and I have the same
problem it's got a little warp in the
Tang it's not hard yeah man and Braxton
is back in the Forge now
I don't believe the Braxton blade was
old enough
to get hard you really have to wait till
the very end of that cooling cycle for
it to skate a pile I'm not going to move
on to the second round pretty sure if I
can't get this off it's pretty fast
I'm going in for the clinch right now
man my biggest concern at this moment is
picking up a warp and uh I'm hoping I
haven't ground off all my mild steel I'm
pretty sure I haven't but
we'll see
I like it shakes blade is maybe one of
the thinnest we've ever had come out of
a round one and narrows
five minutes
squinch
yep
that looks pretty straight it's pretty
straight
it's good Braxton Just quenched again
it's taken me four quenches to get this
blade to the straightness that I want it
it's not as hard as I would like it but
it's gonna have to work
one place fish shut down your machines
drop your tools this first round of
competition is over
blade Smiths and test the strength and
durability of your blades as well as the
overall construction of your knives I'll
be batoning them mercilessly into this
weight plate remember this test is all
about what the plate does to your knives
and not what your knives do to the plate
Braxton Europe first you ready for this
I feel a little nervous but go ahead all
right
that is a piece of metal they're going
to be hitting my blade didn't get as
hard as I wanted to so I'm starting to
cringe
all right
good job man yeah
we're practicing first things first you
can see where I hit those weight plates
the first area is still sharp but bent
over
the second two areas have
significant rolling that being said the
rest of your knife is very sharp
extremely attractive looking knife well
done thank you Kyle you're up next what
are you thinking letter e all right
I am pretty sure my blade can handle it
you know I made it pretty thick pretty
robust to handle that kind of use but
it's hard not to be concerned when
they're going to bash it into a cast
iron plate
that was that Kyle
broke your Tang snapped in half it said
a very critical spot can't hold on to
this for further testing
it broke in the handle where I forged
welded that Milestone Kyle your blade
has suffered a catastrophic failure in
the handle on the second strike however
not out of this competition just yet
Jake that means that your blade needs to
survive two licks against that plate how
you feeling right now
I'm pretty nervous all right Gentlemen
let's see what happens Ben
I know that my Blade's going to be
pretty durable but my Edge is pretty
thin I'm hoping that mine can outperform
his because at this point it's my only
hope to make it
one more as Ben goes to make the second
strike on my blade it's all in slow
motion for me
my heart is in my throat
there you go
Jake congratulations your blade held up
Kyle because your weapon suffered a
catastrophic failure in the handle and
can no longer continue with testing I
have to eliminate you from this
competition hey man it was a pleasure
blades are only as strong as their
weakest point and mine was in the handle
I may not be the forged fire Champion
but finishing a blade and being here was
awesome definitely do it again in a
heartbeat
thank you
[Music]